[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco
nos ponemos deportivos para hablar de
fútbol porque arranca la euro 2020
aplazada por la pandemia aquí a este
verano de 2021 aquí en europa para ello
me acompañan en este estudio juan
palacios periodista deportivo bienvenido
juan tras ya carlos un placer
román way compañera de france 24
bienvenido a román muchas gracias que la
luz buenos días y sin ni colmenares
periodista deportiva cronista en la
radio rtl y comentarista de la euro 2020
en emshi bienvenida gracias carlos
buenos días a todos la euro 2020 hoy se
juega en primera plana
un mes de fútbol por delante el torneo
de selecciones más importante de europa
seguirá llamándose eurocopa 2020 aunque
se juegue en el 2021 desde el 11 de
junio al 11 de julio fútbol en toda
europa y esa es la principal novedad de
este año además de las medidas anti kobe
no se organiza en un país determinado
sino que los partidos se jugarán en 11
ciudades repartidas por todo el
continente en cuanto a los favoritos las
grandes europeas pero sobre todo una
francia con todas sus estrellas ahora
les pregunto por novedades y por
favoritos a mis invitados que espero que
se arriesguen hoy a hacer una apuesta
sobre quién va a ganar esta eurocopa
pero antes vamos a repasar lo que dicen
las portadas diario l'equipe dice aquí
por fin la euro jugando con el 2020 y el
2021 un claro guiño a ese aplazamiento
por la pandemia soy el hombre más feliz
del mundo dice el jugador francés
benzema al diario español marca por su
vuelta a la selección sin duda uno de
los grandes atractivos de esta eurocopa
la gazzetta dello sport en italia llama
la italia del buen juego vuelven los
tifosi con la escuadra nacional y ayer
les pregunto por este buen juego italia
porque no siempre
ambos estos dos conceptos bueno con un
año de retraso y al igual que los juegos
olímpicos llega a la eurocopa juan una
gran prueba de cierto grado de
normalidad en una europa en desescalada
es un diferente pero adaptarnos al
contexto y obviamente una vez de que
esta eurocopa empiece va a comenzar a
rodar el balón la expectativa será
diferente y la tensión del aficionado y
creo que vamos a disfrutar de un gran
torneo la principal novedad no se juega
en un país fijo como en todas las
ediciones anteriores sino que hay 11
sedes distintas vamos a explicar porque
román fue la voluntad de don de el
antiguo presidente de la uefa michel
platini que quería celebrar a la unión
europea con la ocopa así que es por eso
que le indujo deseando que hoy en womad
un dice fui amigo el tratado que creó la
unión europea iba a nacer en el lateral
donde nació el fútbol así que va a ser
un celebración del fútbol
en el fútbol como medio de unificación
de europa desde españa hasta rusia desde
inglaterra hasta bakú
pero esta gran cantidad de países y
sedes con momentos distintos en la des
escalada porque claro que hablar de
deporte pero tenemos que estar hablando
también de la pandemia no nos queda otra
los estadios en algunos países van a
estar llenos en otras sedes van a estar
vacíos esto es un poco cause no si por
ejemplo en budapest van a estar llenos
al cien por ciento que otros países
de hecho dublín no puede ya formar parte
de los países porque no lograron llegar
a éste
dublín que se han preparado como sede se
tuvo que retirar y ahora se retira y
bueno también está la situación que
creemos que está detrás de nosotros pero
fíjense por ejemplo la selección
española con busquets que dio positivo
al cobit y luego luego hubo este riesgo
este falso positivo de diego llorente
también o sea que tenemos todavía esto
un poco encima lo cual dificulta las
cosas sobre todo el hecho que son 12
países pero finalmente el hecho de que
sean 12 países
porque si hubiese habido solamente un
país y un problema o una situación que
sale de control en este país respecto a
la pandemia pues no hubiésemos tenido
otras opciones finalmente a estos reduce
un poco el riesgo porque si tenemos un
país en el cual la situación es difícil
pues hay otros
de igualdad también porque en teoría era
complicadísimo y si en algún momento
azerbaiyán y rumanía hungría podrían
realizar una eurocopa como un solo país
anfitrión y darle esa posibilidad a
todas estas naciones sobre todo a las
ciudades bucarest
bakú budapest creo que es una apertura
para el aficionado que pueda disfrutar
de una alta competencia y sobre todo de
una expectativa de un evento de una
connotación mundial les pregunto el
hecho de que no se juegue en un país
determinado como las anteriores
eurocopas no quita un punto de
romanticismo al torneo hace para robarse
y para sin mil veces y con la cabeza que
también juan normal no bueno de debate
juan no no le quita un punto no porque
imagínate lo que representa para el
aficionado básicamente de azerbaiyán de
de rumanía de hungría de poder albergar
esta eurocopa
es normal vale definitivamente hubo una
postularon hace en algunas otras
ediciones de manera conjunta
azerbaiyán con georgia imagínate pero
esa candidatura no fue validada y ahora
qué lees esa oportunidad creo que a esa
afición de poder ver esta competencia es
algo que le da un encanto distinto
también vamos a hablar de las favoritas
porque si algo se 16 por algo se
distingue a esta eurocopa nos están de
acuerdo es que sí que hay una favorita
sobre el papel según todas las apuestas
a diferencia de otras ediciones de la
eurocopa y este año es francia y además
claramente por el glam el gran plantel
de estrellas que tiene el equipo francés
que tiene vida de jams están de acuerdo
no me imagino decidir en cada línea de
blues vienen súper fuerte obviamente se
habla mucho del trío de ataque con
benzema con griezmann con mbappe pero
también fíjense el match de cante
recientemente el mediocampo que ha
estado siempre muy bueno un poco más de
dificultades a veces en defensa pero en
línea generales el equipo que además
viene como obviamente favorito porque es
campeón del mundo que ha logrado seguir
con ese nivel que llega desde la copa
del mundo sea bueno
teóricamente francia es el favorito
tenemos el mejor equipo pero es un tema
que todas las francesas les piden si fue
fue un continuo de la expectativa si
mucha expectativa para él
se espera que toma la plaza de origen en
ataque que en poque no puso goles en el
mundial puede ser un buen cumplimiento
para mba page man pero si tenemos el
mejor equipo pero en el pasado siempre
en hielo tenemos en 2002 cuando cuando
uno tiene digamos el sambenito de ser
muy favorito para algo hay una presión
añadida extra las lindas sensaciones por
una cuestión de realismo y pasional
cambian sobre todo en este tipo de
competencias porque siempre hay muchos
favoritos de que no hay no colman las
expectativas que pasan a ser de
candidatos a excepción y hay otros
equipos que de repente aparecen con
menos posibilidades
y ocupan la linda historia eso creo que
es lo hermoso que puede dar esta
competencia y ojo francia campeón del
mundo va también con ese rótulo de
candidato pero no hay que olvidar a las
otras elecciones
holanda italia españa alemania son son
grandes equipos y españa que que las dos
últimas bueno en el 2012 y en el 2008
ganó la eurocopa o sea hay que tener en
cuenta también a esto se le critica de
aquella españa de los años que todo lo
que yo situaría entre 2008 y 2012 y ya
sin sergio ramos además en este equipo
no queda absolutamente una selección
sorprendentemente joven quienes también
muchos talentos que pueden ser las
estrellas de hecho de la eurocopa como
pedrique viene del barça o sea es otro
equipo pero yo sinceramente no
en cualquier caso españa no pero siempre
hay una sorpresa cuando hablaste de
otros países puede por ejemplo ser y
acuérdense de islandia en el 2016 que
fue una sorpresa yo pienso en países más
como la naranja mecánica holanda que
regresa a una competencia interna
bélgica que favorita alemania todo este
tipo de países que pueden ver les puede
favorecer esa condición de outsider
porque la presión es distinta la
exposición de los futbolistas va a ser
diferente porque van a adquirir
protagonismo y otra cosa de que españa
está en proceso de transición también o
sea ya nos olvidamos un poco de los
nombres clásicos pero vamos a ver lo que
puedan aportar estos nuevos futbolistas
román francia gran favorita y si bajamos
digamos al siguiente peldaño que equipos
estarían ahí bélgica para mí bélgica
tiene una muy buena generación lo vimos
en el mundial hace dos años que ya no
sería tanto revelación porque ya ahora
vamos muchas citas hablando de bélgica
como revelación ahora ya si llegan a los
heridos tienen su primera la competición
así que y tienen jugadores pero bonitos
que kevin duro aunque como el medio
el mejor mediocampista de comida lic
en involucran p
tiene en él lukaku que hizo una
temporada con un camino muy buena tienen
el tipo postura como google que es muy
bueno quien jugado vez que pueden
agradecer a la diferencia no me han
nombrado a portugal posibilidades menos
favoritas yo hubiese por ejemplo dicho
alemania al maneja alemania también
porque alemania va a jugar en casa eso
le va a ayudar el primer macho es ir
alianza arena está eso está también el
hecho de que final en mont finalmente lo
waking lo va a meter a jugadores como mi
idea es que no estaba a emails o sea
regresan los que aportaban también al
equipo porque se lo cree se criticaba
alemania eran que eran jugadores muy
jóvenes les estaban costando hicieron
buena preparación y me parece que
alemania puede ser nuestro estrecho
alemania y españa tienen el mayor número
de victorias creo en eurocopa no tres
cada uno no sé si tuviera que crear una
cuarta juan usted la apostaría a
alemania o españa
puede determinar mucho el primer juego
alemania va de local frente a la francia
campeona del mundo que si tiene
jugadores que ya llevan una experiencia
importantísima como haberse coronado
campeón del mundo no manuel noya thomas
müller lo tiene a toni kroos marcó royce
creo que es un plan del interesantísimo
y sobre todo dejó una sensación e
ingrata en la última copa del mundo y es
el momento para no solamente de la
reconstrucción es también la posibilidad
de poder tener esa confianza con con la
afición y es la mejor oportunidad en
esta eurocopa siempre va a ser un
candidato alemán ya con ello está de
acuerdo sin de verdad y además se retira
a joaquín globos a team también una
importancia creo para el equipo es un
personaje que es respetado admirado
también por el plantel y creo que sí
puede ser en verdad la sorpresa porque
además está en un grupo que ciertamente
está el grupo de amor
si portugal francia alemania me falta 1
hungría
hungría pero jugado en su estadio en
frente de funcionarios y que se volvió
muy bueno en los últimos años eso es
justamente lo que me preocupa un poco
sobre este tipo de copa es que algunos
países va a estar muy claro favorecido
por esta igualdad no en esto de la multi
sede entonces el 25 o más o sea el
hombre número 12 del equipo el donde un
jugador pactar también entonces es es
complicado para los otros equipos que no
van a jugar nunca en casa me van a dejar
un momentito nos vamos a hacer una breve
pausa vayan pensando en hacer una
apuesta vuelta de pausa porque me van a
decir quién es el favorito de cada uno
de ustedes para ganar está euro 2020
enseguida volvemos en primera plana
[Música]
nuestros equipos recogen los testimonios
de los que viven la noticia una mirada
diferente a la actualidad
vídeos que no verá en ningún otro sitio
los observadores en france 24 y france
24 puntocom
[Música]
seguimos aquí en primera plana de rev y
de france24 esta semana hablando de
fútbol porque se inicia arranca la euro
2020 que se celebra en 2021 lou con mis
compañeros juan palacios síndico
almenares y román web y estábamos
hablando de los favoritos de quién puede
ser la revelación estamos analizando
pues todo lo que va a dar de sí este mes
de fútbol que se inicia en europa
francia sin duda es la gran favorita
para ganar la eurocopa seguida de cerca
según las apuestas de inglaterra y
españa no sólo las apuestas según
también los cálculos de varias
universidades europeas atención expertos
en matemáticas de la universidad de
innsbruck en austria de molde noruega de
dortmund y munich en alemania y de gante
y del gante en bélgica han calculado las
posibilidades de alzarse con el título
de las 24 selecciones participantes en
el torneo que se disputa del 11 de junio
al 11 de julio el único equipo que tiene
cero opciones matemáticas de levantar la
copa
es lo saben hungría es el único que
tiene cero opciones según los
matemáticos atención francia favorita y
después inglaterra y españa coinciden
más o menos con los matemáticos su
visión sin bis francia me encantaría
ganar la eurocopa pero yo creo que la
final será francia alemania me parece
que estos equipos se va a encontrar otra
vez que puede ser alemania vengan y cómo
van los matemáticos bien encaminados o
no roma civil para mi francés favorita y
tengo porque entonces claro pero se
puede hablar de la cabeza y el corazón
en casos de apuestas eso pero en todo
neo siempre hay sorpresas y para mí la
sorpresa que no es tanto una esta pieza
puede ser a inglaterra que tiene una muy
buena selección que van a jugar muchos
partidos en su estadio de wembley pienso
que todo eso hay todo lo que necesita
para un contoneo
al favorito todos le van a querer ganar
soy la predisposición de las elecciones
que van como outsider es totalmente
diferente en ese sentido la selección de
francia tiene que tener mucho cuidado
porque el favoritismo también te puede
dar un jugar una mala pasada entonces
hay selecciones que no emergen como los
candidatos pero están allí y en la
medida que la competencia vaya
evolucionando el rendimiento vaya
creciendo se pueden mostrar otra
expresión futbolística españa porto
portugal por ahí quien sabe lo tiene
cristiano ronaldo y alemania inglaterra
y siempre la selección de la linda
historia que no aparece como el favorito
puede ser una sorpresa
croacia que tuvo una linda historia
también en el 2018 y bélgica que probé
con una generación importantísima esto
en cuanto a puestas por equipos hablemos
de estrellas de esta eurocopa quien va a
destacar sobre todo bueno según todas
las apuestas una empape si me voy a ser
muy original pero sí creo que es un
jugador que viene muy muy fuerte y poco
a poco en este club también hay otros
jugadores de otras selecciones como
pedro a mí me parece que puede ser muy
bueno y quién sabe si cante porque si
por ejemplo francia gana la eurocopa
todo el mundo apuesta a que cante puede
ser el próximo balón de oro porque ganó
la champions league cosa pero me empapé
que todo el mundo cuenta con ello esta
eurocopa puede ser la de que otros
nombres saber juan román a mí me encanta
a los mediocampistas así que voy a decir
algo lo conté y también en la selección
bueno apuntamos más nombres juan alguno
bueno quieres que hablemos los jugadores
confirmados porque la mayoría de las
selecciones tienen nombres destacados
importantísimos o quien puede hacer
revelaciones veracidad vamos a estar que
están en segunda fila que venga mais un
out el que ha realizado una temporada
enorme con chelsea ganador de la liga de
campeones y vamos a ver si lo ratifica a
nivel de un equipo nacional con
inglaterra me parece que es un jugador
interesantísimo por juventud por margen
de progresión y por rendimiento y a
confirmarlo no en esta eurocopa me gusta
mucho la squadra azzurra en italia
porque es verdad que hay no hay
estrellas pero hay muy buenos jugadores
entonces me parece que un móvil o
insignia son jugadores que pueden de
repente también sorprender el operativo
conocemos muy bien en francia pero puede
ser una sorpresa además en los partidos
de preparación ha hecho muy buenos
partidos de preparación italia llega con
varias victorias seguidas 40 es así si
estaban en muy buena posición y llegan
sin ese ese peso de ser estrellas y
además ellos no estuvieron presentes
en la copa del mundo 2018 o sea que
vienen con todo ese ánimo de estar otra
vez una competencia internacional quién
sabe si lo decía antes cuando repasaba
la prensa la gazzetta dello sport que
hablaba de vuelve italia vuelve los
tifosi vuelve y decía el 'jogo bonito'
que realmente no asociamos a italia con
esa idea del juego sino que la asociamos
con el cut en action con el juego está
viendo ahorita se está viendo como una
selección unida muy feliz que juega
bonito de hecho al fútbol y quién sabe
si de repente también tiene holanda que
tienen jugadores muy buenos como tenías
de jong de piper eso ya son las en
verdad las grandes estrellas pero bueno
puede ser sorpresas por eso un lado
román para mí la sorpresa la revelación
puede ser también en inglaterra moon
estoy de acuerdo pero también hay que
vigilar
phil foto que hizo una jugada
excepcional con el manchester city así
que si puedo ya sea mi joven que quiera
vamos al tanto del plano deportivo pero
también al plano kobe que no lo podemos
dejar al margen a diferencia de las
olimpiadas bueno aquí no todas las
elecciones se han vacunado ha habido un
lío de vacunas
en algunas que llegan vacunadas hay
otras que no españa ha tenido un lío de
vacunas tremendo
lío político lío deportivo síndic porque
normalmente la federación española
quería que los jugadores fueron
vacunados y por qué no porque los
atletas de los juegos olímpicos fueron
vacunados pero hubo un problema con el
ministerio de la salud que consideró que
no era necesario y ahora lo van a hacer
hoy normalmente todos los jugadores
estarán vacunados claro siempre con los
efectos que después como en francia
siempre es una decisión de los jugadores
no se les impone pero obviamente se le
da la oportunidad que puedan ser
vacunados y eviten todos estos viajes y
luego está el tema de los espectadores
en los estadios porque claro aquí
corremos como hay tantas sedes en tantos
países que muchos políticos intenten
hacer escaparate político de lo bien que
vaya desde escalada en sus países no
dice sencillo la política conocen la
pandemia en el eurocopa por ejemplo
cuando no se sabía si se podría jugar
voy johnson propuso tomar toda la
competencia en inglaterra porque tenía
la vacuna con astrazéneca
se volvía a la normalidad en su país y
que hallamos talgo a todo el mundo que
su partido
funcionó y también lo hizo víctor banner
en budapest en hungría
el estadio va a ser lleno de aficionados
y es también para mostrar que aquí que
está caminado es que es curioso esta
eurocopa de diferentes niveles de
desescalada donde también se
entremezclan la política con el deporte
juan y en san petesburgo en rusia el
segundo partido con la totalidad de la
capacidad habilitada mientras que en
otras sedes tal vez a la mitad tal vez
mucho menor hay un contexto político de
fondo pero esto determina del querer
mostrar de la situación por la que viene
afrontando el cada país y sobre todo no
de qué
el miedo ya se ha ido superando y esto
se va a evidenciar con la presencia de
los espectadores en los estadios
volviendo al plano deportivo vamos
cambiando el plano político del plano
kovic pero también al plano deportivo
podemos decir que francia quizá es el
mejor ataque no de si es el mejor ataque
el punto flojo de francia punto.com
román quizá es la defensa pero es un
un punto muy relajado muy relativo
porque tenemos aquí entended adán
hernández espadas que son muy buenos
jugadores así que si puedo ya sea la
defensa
o quizás sí mismo hemos visto con las
declaraciones de edición en contra
embate se supone puede ser a su vez un
miniescándalo en francia como lo estaba
comentando porque va p
dijo cuando un periodista le preguntó
dice que bp combate no tiene mucho el
balón no lo recibe pero estas son cosas
a mí me parecen muy normales en los
machos de preparación
obviamente benzema
luego de una ausencia un poco larga
entonces están esos ajustes que se están
haciendo pero pienso que de jong siempre
tiene la mano sobre el equipo francés es
muy respetado en el equipo de francia de
jong y creo que he deseado todo estará
muy bien la gestión del grupo sobre todo
sí que es importante esa gestión del
grupo en torneos como una eurocopa esa
psicología ahora por nombres francia
asusta y decimos estamos frente tal vez
a la mejor selección del mundo porque ha
sido el último ganador de del mundial
pero vayamos a las configuraciones
también porque están los rivales o sea
los técnicos están pensando los
adversarios cómo afrontarlos como
anularlos como tomar protagonismo frente
a la que en teoría es la mejor selección
del mundo es por eso de qué
es un punto importantísimo pero también
de repente ese favoritismo le puede
jugar en contra puede ser un factor
negativo tiene a los hombres pero
vayamos a ver si no solamente es el
colectivo sino las individualidades que
tienen que marcar la diferencia pero no
se olviden que lo del favoritismo cuando
estuvo la copa del mundo francia decían
que podría ser uno favorito y luego
empezaron a ver los primeros avances se
dieron cuenta que francia finalmente no
estaba jugando de manera muy
espectacular y luego sorpresa francia
campeón del mundo pueden ser muy
exigentes porque quieren ver buenos
partidos calidad de juego el resultado
espectáculo y todo ese conjunto es
bastante complicado también no porque
quieres una gran expresión futbolística
pero básicamente uno tiene que priorizar
el resultado juegue bien puede mal pero
sobre todo conseguir los tres puntos
vamos a hacer apuesta vamos a hacer
apuesta de quien creen que va a ganar o
quien quieren y creen que que va a ganar
buena por quién empieza por román coma
mega bueno yo vine tomando nota y
veremos dentro de un mes quién ha ganado
esta cuesta a quién va a ganar la
eurocopa llegó franza quieres o crees
que yo quiero francia cuando acento lo
habíamos si bien notado y yo bélgica y
crees bélgica muy bien
si me quiero que gane mi país de
adopción francia pero pienso que va a
ganar alemania
pero piensas que va a ganar además juan
es muy complicado los candidatos está
ahí y están ahí y francia- de confirmar
pero sobre todo es muy difícil teniendo
en cuenta las selecciones de alemania
italia que no eran nombrados pocos no le
hemos nombrado casi croacia holanda y
por ahí de repente alguna alguna otra
sorpresa
porque si dices a todos no no sería
quien te interesa o quién quieres
alemania o españa
uno bueno alemania alemania y yo creo
que voy a estar de acuerdo con román yo
creo que en bélgica yo que con españa
pero creo que bélgica así que tenemos
dos que creen que alemania y nosotros
dos que creemos que bélgica
bueno pues dentro de un mes veremos
quién tiene a ganador quien ha ganado la
apuesta fija fíjense que ninguno hemos
dicho que queremos que va a ser francia
hemos descartado a la favorita por algo
queremos y si veremos lo que un poco
[Música]
presa que para nadie muchísimas gracias
ha sido un programa pues muy divertido y
muy interesante hablando del euro ya
todos ustedes que pasen un buen mes
futbolístico y hasta la próxima semana
quien en primera plana gracias
[Música]